en el sentido
[Música]
somos un grupo de 26 personas que
llevamos varios días aquí entre la
frontera entre belarús
la única forma de salir de belarús es
entrando a polonia
y la única forma de salir de polonia es
entrando a ver la luz
estamos bloqueados en las fronteras como
pueden ver lo hace frío por favor
ayúdennos
estos hombres y niños están atrapados en
europa del este
estamos sufriendo por favor ayúdenos
desde este verano nuestros observadores
nos han alertado de los peligros de esta
nueva ruta migratoria que pasa por el
bosque entre polonia y belarús
los migrantes vienen de siria yemen o la
república democrática del congo pensando
que pueden llegar a la unión europea
en respuesta a las sanciones impuestas
por reunión europea belarús se le acusa
de facilitarles a los migrantes que
llegan por vía aérea el acceso a visas
de turismo y de animarlos a cruzar las
fronteras europeas
polonia ha registrado 16.000 intentos de
entrada ilegal desde julio
pero el gobierno nacional conservador de
polonia que dice temer que haya
terroristas entre los migrantes está
optando por responder con seguridad
las devoluciones a belarús son
sistemáticas y se va a construir un muro
a lo largo de la frontera
en la región fronteriza de portlan ya
nos reunimos con activistas de la
fundación de salem ya ellos reciben
alertas y posiciones geográficas de
grupos de migrantes que se encuentran
del lado polaco
cerca de un pueblo una familia del
kurdistán iraquí escapó del control de
los guardas fronterizos
este hombre dice haber viajado más de
siete días de belarús con sus hijos de
quienes no dice nada
watts monya
pasa
jugar papas
un integrante de la fundación salen ya
les da comida agua y abrigo su colega
piot explica que la única posibilidad de
evitar la evolución de esta familia es
ayudarles a solicitar asilo
y
allí le darán un poder a una persona de
aquí y esta persona llamará a los
guardias fronterizos y les pedirá que
vengan ella les ayudará con los trámites
para solicitar protección internacional
en polonia
la protección internacional está
reservada a las personas que huyen de
conflictos o persecuciones implica
querer quedarse en polonia y llamar a
los guardas fronterizos
esperamos su llegada durante dos horas
la noche mejor
[Aplausos]
y cuál es su plan porque soy su
representante
un momento por favor está de acuerdo
carolina se ofreció a ayudar a la foto
de uno quiere presionar con la ayuda de
la prensa porque el parlamento polaco
autorizó a los guardas fronterizos a
devolver a los migrantes ordenaron
aunque sean
pero a mí me gustaría presentar la
solicitud del nombre de estas personas
de este caballero al que represento
venga por aquí el señor queremos
presentar una solicitud de protección
internacional qué va a pasar con esta
gente con estos niños espere le
informaría podría explicarnos lo que
está pasando se los van a llevar a mi
hija lobo al puesto de la guardia
fronteriza a 15 minutos de aquí
[Aplausos]
a veces se llevar a la gente al bosque
incluso a los niños por eso vamos a
seguirlos e intentaremos permanecer en
contacto con ellos
[Aplausos]
la familia fue llevada micha logo al
puesto de guardia fronterizo donde
continúa la negociación
carolinas human scouts soy la
representante de las personas que iban a
ser traídas aquí a níjar lobo el padre y
sus cuatro hijos dormirán en este puesto
por el momento la familia no será
devuelta a la frontera pero el proceso
aún está
la familia pudo recibir ayuda porque
consiguió pasar la frontera de la zona
del estado de emergencia una franja de
tres kilómetros de la frontera polaca
que está cerrada a las organizaciones y
a los periodistas
[Música]
pero esta carretera está cerrada
pero no muy lejos de este cordón vemos
patrullas de policía un grupo de cuatro
personas fue detenido quiénes son ellos
no podemos decir nada
puede hablar con nuestro vocero el
número está disponible en internet y
usted bien lo sabe
llegan los refuerzos
entonces los guardias fronterizos se
dieron estos dobles son sí
[Aplausos]
los cuatro hombres finalmente fueron
enviados de vuelta de la luz sin embargo
según las naciones unidas estas
devoluciones son contrarias al derecho
internacional
a lo largo de la ruta fronteriza los
migrantes se encuentran solos y
desamparados entre los guardas
fronterizos polacos y vieux los rusos
youseff uno de nuestros observadores
congoleños comparte su desesperación
otro observador a quien llamaremos
nelson nos envía estas imágenes y este
testimonio
y nos encontramos con algunos soldados
polacos el dije soy del congo y me
gustaría pedir asilo aquí me dijeron no
vas a hacer nada y empezaron a llevarnos
por la fuerza y nos llevaron de vuelta a
la frontera polo
copa davis
y
esa fue la primera noche que pasamos
afuera con mis hijos hicimos una fogata
improvisada porque hacía mucho frío y
estaba muy oscuro
no había luz no había ni nada
nelson compara su situación con un
partido de ping pong entre los dos
países ya que belarús se niega a acoger
a los migrantes que ya han cruzado al
lado europeo
desde septiembre al menos siete personas
han muerto por agotamiento o hipotermia
en el bosque
en la región fronteriza la pequeña
ciudad de mira logo preocupada por la
proximidad de un invierno muy crudo
estableció un punto de ayuda
como pueden ver recibimos ropa abrigada
chaquetas y muchas de ellas son para
niños
y estas son cosas que han traído los
habitantes de la zona o de todo polonia
de toda polonia anoche estábamos a 0
grados cada vez hace más frío también
disponemos de una ambulancia por si se
necesita ayuda médica
este centro lleva abierto 4 días pero
ningún migrante ha venido a pesar de los
carteles que los bomberos han colgado en
el bosque inglés
si viene aquí les informaremos a los
guardias fronterizos porque como saben
tienen que decirnos si quieren pedir el
asilo o no pero al menos avanzan con eso
podemos darles comida o ropa
obligada a declarar a los migrantes que
se detienen en este punto de ayuda la
alcaldía asegura que estas solicitudes
de asilo tendrán acompañamiento los
migrantes podrán descansar pero
eventualmente serán devueltos a la
frontera
puede parecer tonto pero nos gustaría
saber cómo podemos ayudar
vamos a tomar los datos de las personas
que quieren ayudar
en todo caso este punto de ayuda
demuestra que la situación moviliza a
los colegios mayra viajó 400 kilómetros
para venir hasta aquí
hay niños en el bosque hace frío y
llueve
es imposible lo que está pasando aquí no
podemos dejar a la gente así en el
bosque
su auto está lleno de cosas e ir a
distribuirlas a las organizaciones que
ayudan tanto como pueden a los migrantes
en el bosque
la política del gobierno cuenta con un
amplio apoyo en polonia pero en la
región fronteriza algunos habitantes
intentan alojar a estos migrantes sin
informar a los guardias fronterizos en
la casa de un habitante que pide el
anonimato
nos encontramos con hossein un iraquí de
20 años de bagdad
[Música]
camino un día entero sin zapatos caminé
por pantanos y bebía agua sucia no tenía
más camisas no teníamos ropa
en las redes sociales en facebook y
youtube había información que dice que
es fácil cruzar
llegas hasta polonia y luego a alemania
a los países europeos que son buenos
en irak no hay vida en irak ahora no se
vive venimos a buscar un país para
sentir nuestros derechos para tener un
trabajo
esta noche joseín emprenderá el camino
de nuevo espera llegar a varsovia y
luego tomar un tren hacia alemania
[Música]
[Aplausos]
en varsovia en el ministerio de asuntos
exteriores polaco se culpa de la
situación al jefe de estado de belarús
alexander lukashenko
el objetivo y la meta de lukashenko es
provocar una discusión muy emotiva al
respecto quiero decir esto es una crisis
artificial
grandes continuos usando las alteración
[__]
por supuesto que se encuentran en una
situación muy delicada y difícil si
pasan noches y días en el bosque y estoy
seguro de que conocían el riesgo podemos
considerar esta crisis desde un punto de
vista humanitario qué es lo que usted
está intentando hacer pero también
deberíamos considerar este problema
desde el otro lado es decir es una
cuestión de seguridad de nuestro país y
nuestra comunidad
en octubre de polonia y otros 11 países
de la unión europea le pidieron a
bruselas que financiará la construcción
de vallas anti migrantes la comisaria
europea de asuntos de interior dijo que
prefería evitar la financiación con
fondos de la unión europea pero que no
se opone a este proyecto